pepe 17e author of Chow America how do
you translate that from Italian
originally was an Italian in America
which an Italian America but i have to
say i like how America better I mean in
italian America you know you may think
it's a story about immigration or which
is not its story about in Italian or may
I say a European because it's very much
a triangular book that is a very British
element there i lived in Britain hello
my English there and so it's like a
North European South european-american
book which chow mein well you know that
ciao means hello and the the name beppi
short for Josette pen it's like bourbon
Robert and sever Nene what part of Italy
does that name come from northern Italy
it comes from a little town called crema
which is 35,000 people 30 miles from
Milan southeast of Milan in lombardy is
well my family comes from and I see
lived that I travel I lived in of course
in this country in this town I lived in
in Moscow I lived in london and brussels
but back home what do you do for a
living full-time that's a good question
I'm a journalist I used to be like a
staff journalist and I've been on
foreign correspondent then I write books
and I have my own television program in
Italy for Italian television and I do
some radio so it's an it's not unusual
what I do for America someone in America
I know people that you know have similar
jobs in in a way you know for instance
mike kinsley you know he has been with
the car to the economist as I have I
write for The Economist by the way I
mean that I've been the Italian
correspondent for six years I'm still
I'm in America in my professional
position it wouldn't be unusual it is a
little unusual in Italy columnist that's
what I am it's not any tiny can hardly
be translated into Italian sort of job
market what's this book about your
country
where'd you get the idea yeah I decided
that I learned when I arrived in to live
here I read so many books about this
country but nobody told me they are the
many surprises at a daily life had in
store for me and I think that say I
decided that really there was there was
a niche and they need if I may uh for a
book that would explain how America
works what a matter what makes America
tick the way you drink eat by and there
wasn't such a book and the book in Italy
when tremendously well but really
tremendously way it is the classic book
Italians coming to work in Washington or
the word bank or all to you know to
leave here I married here you name it is
you know they all know about the book
many have that book in the Italian
version because it helped them to
understand America and now I do hope
sincerely that it would be useful for
Americans to understand not their
country they know it but maybe to find a
new angle to look at your own daily
thing with new eyes I'll be very proud
when I read a book one of the first
times I noticed that it wasn't a book
written last year was when you had Strom
Thurmond at 92 years old and he's now 99
so this book was originally done in 95
why is it now just being published in
the United States 2002 you want an
honest answer because you sell books all
over the world you don't buy very many
and it's very very unusual for an
Italian also to be sitting here at
c-span answer your question with an
American book and very proud maybe
because many foreigners cannot come and
talk to you because they their english
is not but be but because America and
that's one little criticism I'm a great
friend of America I like America you
cannot write a book like this if you
don't like a country I wrote similar
book slightly different but about
Britain 10 years ago and it worked very
well in Britain as well because I like
Britain America as it took an today
no I know the language I live there and
so on if you try to write such a book
about a country that you do not like
that you don't feel affection for is a
disaster everything you say it's nasty
there is a several book one of them is
it is out now there is a lot of debate
about it and and the bottom line is that
you sound judgmental you sound sort of
copying it it's no good I like America
if you like something you could end it
if your country is your friend it's like
your friends if you have your friends
you can tell them things you can
criticize them you can take you know the
mickey out of them you can tease them
it's okay because it's so obvious that
you like them so why the seven year
delay and publishing it here I mean what
was the dynamic of all of a sudden some
I said well as you don bah it's not easy
to sell a book to the American market
therefore the book had to be a success
and a real one in Europe then we decided
with my posture which is Rizzoli to have
a limited edition in English which was
exported here I will see a last year's
promote that's little addition a few
thousand copies The Washington Post
someone saw the book they loved the book
they wrote a big story because the big
story that Bob became number 8 overall
on amazon com which is you know what is
this book nobody knows about and broadly
books so all this stuff and I say we
want to do it but you see it's not easy
it was an Italian how many American
publishers don't have you know scores of
people that read Italian and judge the
book 1513 34 straight Georgetown your
book revolves around that absolutely why
because I decided America is complicated
and to be in one place to stay put to
decide here it is volta park they jun 9
i'm very pleased i'm not in Washington
jun 9th because otherwise i'd be there
slaving for some lady living there where
is this volta park is like Islam
a hundred feet from where I live I live
down there I love that and how long did
you live there like 14 months here we
are here we are which house is yours the
white one the white one but it's a
little brass plaque now it says only
Italian in America was the new owner
who's a friend isn't it now he's a
friend he loves the idea of living in
the literary houses he says and he put a
little plaques in italiano in America so
he say when my readers go there and they
go there often is on the right is is a
golden thing there when they go there he
doesn't have to tell them yes these were
better rodas book this is the book of
Baptists a Bernini so they know
Georgetown you say has 3,000 houses in
it that's what I heard and you live
there for how long at 12 months what
year was it nine between 94 95 and I
updated the book in two thousand i leave
another two weeks and i updated the book
and i try to describe what happened and
what what changed so what is it about
that part of America that is is it
unique by the way I mean is it is ever
all of America like this area you think
I'm just sorry I'm just looking it's
Miracle on thirty-fourth Street that's
it would have been a good title because
it's a miracle that this book went so
well after just one year in living there
now to answer your question yes I do
believe that America inside the beltway
looks very much like America outside the
beltway I believe that is myth this idea
of Washington insa being old politics
and power and you name it inside it is
true where you got people buying living
hoping sending children to school taking
their you know their dogs for a walk
doing a lot of things that are very
American and they do them inside the
beltway in Georgetown exactly as they do
them in maine cancer so Arizona how much
of the united states have you seen a lot
i first came in 1977 I was a 20 years
old young man Elvis Presley died I
missed the news completely simply
because my English is very poor at the
time I travel coast to coast with
/ and five friends I came back many
times i would say in the last 10 years i
was back every 2-3 times a year all
together like 30 times and but living
here was different the idea was when i
moved to the house I knew America enough
to know what I was talking about but not
so well that I would not be surprised
and surprise is the key to a book like
this so it was like a magic moment
that's why i say Miracle on
thirty-fourth Street is a magic moment
you know enough you're not bored you are
still curious you want to see look at
details details are the key to this book
you say that in Britain the first words
that are the first word that a child
learns is pleased but the first words
that American children learn our I am
great yes I think that's it a a kind of
a writer's way to add to explain the
differences between the two countries in
Britain that is a kind of white attitude
to life understatement starts from your
childhood your your parents don't really
care much for you if you were a pet they
would it's a children are you know on
their own now you know we brought you
into the world now you fend for yourself
which is ok I mean there that the way to
approaching thing America is difficult
it's different is its you want to give
your your children the right attitude
the positive attitude you know and go
and get it attitude of being you know
not a loser by the winner and Cheever
and and all that and that's why i summed
it up is first word for a British child
please first word for an American child
I'm the greatest like Muhammad Ali is
that a good idea I think to be honest
that something in between it would
probably be a good idea you know yes
give your children the right attitude to
give you confidence basically but also
explained to them that
they may lose in life it's very
important I take my child to football
matches by the way Italy one with
Ecuador today is a beautiful day and I
because I want him to understand that
you can lose your team can be very good
but you can do losing the idea of being
of understanding and I think sometimes
there is a little problem there let's be
an example to explain what I mean I
heard of a test for attitude for people
as I as young as two and a half three to
be admitted in nursery schools of course
children Donald don't know what they are
doing and don't care but I I my American
friends we're in tatters while they were
doing this and I think to to put
children and their parents were they
very young with children through such a
stress is probably wrong how much
education do you have you mean back in
Europe yeah I I have a law degree and I
started after a University where did you
study for your law degree pavia
University one of the oldest in Italy
founded in the 800 very old very proud
of my university how long did you spend
in England five years what years I lived
in lingdon between 84 and 88 then I went
back in 93 when I worst I was tough at
the economist I was seconded there and
then again in England I first went to
England as a kid to learn English in
1972 and I was lost in London like two
weeks ago or something so countries the
country that I know well you say that
Americans tell you more about themselves
in one hour than the British do in 10
years no I said 20 years yeah with yes
Americans I like American tend to be
open and and friendly I think probably a
little less friendly than they used to
be I think what happened
in on September 11th left a deep scar is
understandable you can see the sometimes
that fantastic trust in other people and
it has been sort of eroded somehow and
is understandable sometimes sorry if i
don't answer your question in media will
go into that in two minute i sometimes I
have the feeling that people back in
Europe do not grasp the enormity of what
happened when people tell me and start
to talk about it and I'll and they say
whatever terrible but I just stopped a
sec but no no but but ISM is one is a
European disease at the moment the
battle no but if you understand what
happened you should you are you you are
Italian can you imagine some Peters and
the Duomo in Milan full of people being
attacked demolished and thousands of
people die you lose two symbols of your
country and many thousand of your
countrymen out of the blue or you're
British can you imagine Wembley Stadium
and some poles country you just give
them and then people realize how hugely
what are you jit is America has been so
spectacularly in film and movies that
some in some back in the back up in some
recess of the European mind there is
this idea that what happened is not
entirely true they seen it on television
I don't know how to explain I should
have busloads taking two grounds here
I've been there too you know really to
really happen anyway to go back to your
to your to your question yes America are
still very open they talk to you and
socially they tend to answer question is
a big shock for us we asked question we
don't really expect an answer you want
because some questions not you know your
questions need answer you ask me
question we're here sitting in front of
each other and I'm supposed to answer
your question if you are an FBI agent I
would answer question up for a different
reason but in conversation cocktail
parties people ask you
no questions or you ask people question
when you have your last pin to Europe
and and they tell you and they really
tell you and they tell you you know I've
been to Europe last year and they tell
you whatever what they've done in Europe
how long they have been in Europe what
they eat they like what they see in
Europe and and you're shocked you say
come on come on hold on I was not it was
not a real question you know it's a
cocktail party I don't want to eat too
many olives that's what I'm talking
that's what cocktail parties are about
and Americans give you answers I love
that what's the big difference between
it being an Italian and in America well
let's let's stick to conversation to
answer these other question an Italian
answer is is a way of very often we
answered with another answer sorry we
answer a question with another question
a Brit answer with the joke which is a
nice way of not answering question very
often a German answer with a little
essay an American answer with an answer
and to be an Italian it's tricky because
you have to understand all these and but
it's okay I think sometimes we have to
learn to be precise an appointment 10-15
mins 1015 to give proper answer to use a
lot of numbers and figures which you
love I mean America is a when you put
some figures two things you love that I
can see that there is a kind of physical
pleasure of putting numbers to think we
don't use we don't do that as much as
you do well we have to learn to do that
a little italy what 60 million people
yeah Barca 285 million do you feel the
difference in the size and the countries
well I'm European too I leave in a con
in a in a content on a continent where
we we are little bit more i think we are
320 million or something so and we have
a cell phone they work all over the
place which is something that somehow me
amira another miracle i don't know how
we achieve that in Europe we did we are
a little
ahead of American in technology in just
in that field that feel teletext not
much else so we and we have a common
currency we have an error in Europe
where we didn't we need no passport so
yes i mean if i were just Italian i
would probably be kinda sort of in all
and and shocked by the side of this
country I'm European so I have traveled
around Europe a lot now I'm not worried
in the book you talk about going to
Dahlgren chapel on the Georgetown
University campus Catholic yes it does
Jesuit are you a Catholic yes the reason
I bring it up is it what's the
difference between being an Italian
Catholic and an American Catholic and
especially in this period that we're
going through here I love that question
because I just been last Sunday I've
been back to dagger in chapel I can say
that their air conditioning is not as
Extreme as he was I normally would go
there dressed like an Eskimo Inn in
anjuna July because he was so cold and I
even took notes yesterday you didn't
know this so he said I took notes it's a
what changed because how fantastically
was yesterday to go in and see they
still they they have a sense of humor
when that when during the sermon that is
they have a sense of you and they use
jokes unheard of in Italy people
actually are a community they talk to
each other they hug each other they tell
each other you know I was informally
lady next to me that is in the book but
he happen again on Sunday you know why
she was there who she was when they tell
you know think you know about pray for
your loved ones and people actually
named mention names aloud you know
Nicholas George and then say about your
loved one who died and people say you
know my father my grandfather I said my
mother I mean I like that I think there
is a kind of open approached and even
this horrible scandal that happen in
this country
the catholic church and i hope the Pope
is going to be as determined as it seems
he wants to be they were they talked
about that at mass ah it's not that they
don't talk about it in Italy but but
there is a kind of some subjects am a
better not to be brought up in certain
okay there is an openness which I kind
of like theirs theirs in some I've read
this and you know seeing it even that
there's some sense that in Italy they
the Catholics don't go to church and in
America they all go to church I mean
comparatively speaking well experience
like this that icon sunday mornings a
the women all go to church in the men
are some well I live in northern Italy
in a small town we tend to go to church
my child who'd like to go and play
soccer but it can't the church and and
so but it is true you'll tend to go less
and less well in America you can see a
young country that's a real crucial
thing you can see a young country if you
look at the way you do things from you
know when you go to war when you play
sports and when you are inside the
church you can see the enthusiam of a
young country who discovers new things
you can see you know they were singing
in Spanish yesterday and does that
Chapel and there were a lot of mixed
couples like a Latino and an Italian and
anglo-saxon and you name it and an Asian
you can see America's young you don't
know how young you are if you're not in
European you come here you can see how
crisp it is the way america in the
america does many thing in a crisp way
that's a key word crisp which I like
there are a lot of things you talk about
in your book and i'm going to give you
just a bunch to expound on just go down
the list of summer i'll try to be quick
read a lot of ground credit cards a
nightmare they didn't want to give me
one I had no credit history no dance I
pay my car the color of my car for
Taurus in cash apparently only Italian
tourist and Colombian drug traffickers
use cash in this country they were a
poll that I did that say you have no
credit history no credit card it was a
drama then I managed to have my Italian
credit card converted into an American
one not a good memory once I had one
credit card they all wanted to give me a
credit card and I say no thank you you
say that Americans used the refrigerator
door to communicate it is true I think
the Internet is isn't is an expansion of
this concept that people put things on
their refrigerator door I was staying
with friends very nice friends I'm still
staying with them now during this visit
and we talk to each other putting little
notes on the refrigerator door I like
that is that a grand that's a they dddd
the good the refrigerator door is a sort
of is a grandmother of email do you not
do that in Italy of course refrigerator
door are to keep their figure 8 or shot
what about freshfields you went to fresh
feels and what you see there you can't
aesthetics of food you pay you know the
price is half for what you see and half
of what you eat I prefer to pay I would
prefer to pay half the price but i
really admire a fresh frills i I think
it's a fascinating place is a little
eerie people are very much on their own
is like a communication between between
like a you know a woman and her and
helped tomatoes is like an encounter
she's talking to them and evaluating
them and then she moves to the wine
department people don't look at each
other so concentrated on these objects
and then all these are new things and
you everything is organic I asked is
this I did it on purpose I saw some flat
peaches and I say all these peaches
genetically genetically modified aha no
nothing is genetically modified in here
I like that an itemized phone bill
I liked it you know now they are more
commonly in in Italy too but you have to
ask for them in Europe they are seen as
an invasion of your privacy while here
rightly they are seniors the way of
checking what you how much you pay and
when smoking poor smokers I I don't
smoke I don't like tobacco companies and
I don't want to go into that but I'm not
a lobbyist for them at all but sometimes
when I see smokers I see them you know
like group of homeless outside building
in the middle of the winter in
Washington downtown Washington or no man
hath and you see them smoking there they
look like drug addicts which maybe they
are I don't know where you want to go
and huddle them as I come on have some
coffee I don't think why you put no
smoking signs in this country you
shouldn't you just put everything a you
can smoke here is one of the 25 places
in the United States where you can
actually smoke so inform people now in
Italy still a lot of smoking going on
well worse than that what happens is
very often that our no smoke inside
think hospitals and you have a doctor
smoking away in the in the corridors it
happens in knock everywhere but it
happens real problem with Italy and the
one thing that I like about this country
there are things that I like Italy I
think it is better and ahead other
states but the one thing there are many
things the states are head of Italy it's
not a book to say who's better those
book our waste of time but they think
that in America is good you got a rule
you're going to respect the rule you do
not respect the rule you're going to be
a fine or depends on what you do in
Italy you got a rule but that often is
an opinion you got a red light and
peeling is an advice you know you better
stop you know what in in Florence they
have a lovely expression called rosso
piano a full red means it's a red there
really is a red because you don't see
who's coming so you better stop but
implies that you got many other forms in
shades of red that if you see who's
coming then after all no one is coming
or you have a red but it's a school a
pedestrian red is eleven o'clock at
night nobody's coming come on that kind
of thing is fantastic you have a rule
but you want to interpret it you want to
decide whether that particular rule
applies to your own very special case in
that very moment that's not good either
this on a nation in C is a collection of
individuals I sometime thing what do you
like better about Italy that this
collection of individuals the fact that
we all feel we are special cases gives
us a lot of stamina and fantasy and
pride and and that's good very often
Northern European which are better
organized and we are tend to be not all
but sometimes our life tend to be gold
they tend to be sad Italians have no
time for sadness they're too busy
dealing with their daily life let me
take you very serious subjects such as
suicides the percentage in Italy is very
very low because people are just
basically too busy battling with their
life sometimes when you have it too easy
I'm not saying that in order to bring
down the suicide rate you have to be
disorganized I'm just saying that Italy
is is a lively country is a country
where where there is a fantasy there is
no such thing as a standard encounter
everything is a is a happening that's
why Americans and the British and the
Germans like it so much because you have
the feeling that everything can happen
it can be good or bad but you know every
day is different from the other one why
do you Americans like America because is
their country because they built it
because they is an experiment which is
still going on not because it's the most
powerful country in the world I don't
think that the answer is because you're
trying something spectacular which is a
country of
people coming from different background
trying to find something together now
that unites you the melting pot okay
call it the melting pot but it's now
something more sophisticated than that I
seen young Chinese students in Boston or
in berkeley coming over they are so lost
after six months they have a baseball
cap after a year the baseball cap is
turn around just like in the cover of my
book Federico da Montefeltro yes like
him who is this this guy is not me
although he's got a funny nose as i have
now if this chap is Federico da
Montefeltro was the Duca Derby no is a
dookie nobody now in the 15th century I
think was 15th century yes and there was
a lovely painting by piero della
francesca and his enough it's in
florence that particular painting anyway
going back to this chinese students he's
got these baseball cap it's got a pack
of jensen backpack and and track shoes
and here is you got almost an America
and he stays here you know all his life
is children will be complete the America
what is about America so powerful I
think the American daily life is a very
very powerful can I say solvent
something that deludes everything into
which is more than the melting pot is
fascinated that s'what I try to look at
a book what is the secret of America why
America is so addictive what did you
find in American motels predictability I
love that i live in a country which is
unpredictable i just told you and to
find a place where everything is
absolutely the same remote control
television not so comfortable bad
because is easy to be too large with
with acrylic often bed sheets the
bathroom is always there it's plastic
that pretend to be pretends to be marble
all that the switch all is there thank
you know where it is at night you go
into a European hotel you have to
go around you know you're touching
frisking the wall and your own trying to
find the switch liberal return policy
dangerous what do you mean by that
anyway well dangerous because you buy
more now that I mean liberal return
policy we mean spline the dish as well
okay leave and return point you mean you
can buy things and return them if you
not if you do not like them that's so
obvious to you that you probably don't
know or think about it because it's
obvious yeah move your mic up a little
bit cuz you're about to lose it and
people won't be able to hear ya thank
you know why because I wave because I
tell you that's why i like i like if i
don't wave i feel and in England and in
America i waive a lot less I tend to
wait you're in reviews yes in Italy you
should see me if you start speaking
Italian a your listener wouldn't
understand apart from few Italians and
be my microphone will be all over the
place feel free to wave I want you to be
yourself but I just wanted to know
you're losing it there go back to the
liberal return policy when did you first
notice that when i realized i was buying
too much and i was buying too much
because i knew i could return things of
course i didn't return anything i just
bought too much and you know what I even
use coupons that's something that proved
to me that America is such a powerful
country coupons the idea of me cutting
out coupons of newspaper it's nobody
does that in your you we got coupons but
there's there there nobody touches them
really of course my coupons is a is a is
one of the mystery of this country
what's the return policy in Europe you
buy and you shut up you don't return you
don't very often because you can't and
if you can they make it so difficult you
have a credit but you cannot have cash
refund you have old you know once I told
a one I was playing these two to a
friend who wants big
shop in Milan and say why don't you is
people would buy more if they know they
can return things and he said you must
be joking people come on Friday to buy
very nice sort of jacket and dinner
jacket or tiger a woman and they will
return in on Monday say what you really
didn't like it then they use it all that
we can I don't think you would have come
at what this answer was what about two
people talking to one another you point
out in the book that there's a
difference in the way when two people
two Americans are standing talking to
one another compared to when two
Italians you're talking to whatever what
many difference is a you tend to stay
closer to each other for some reason I
don't know why be you 10 we discussed
that already you tend to answer question
and your conversation really factual you
you ask a question you want an answer
see you know each other's name I'm
fascinated by that and I know your name
but because I but believe me if this was
an Italian interview my dear brian i
wouldn't know your name because you told
me your name but then i would forget it
and then i would find some strange
devious way to find out what your name
is socially is it is a tragedy for
Italians Italian who live in Italy will
come over to America because you're
sitting down at dinner with a lady who
tells your name Beth hey Beth a mighty a
better that and she knows the moment you
tell her something clicks in a brain and
she knows better forever she's going to
pass that information on to successive
generation that your name is better she
told her she told you you know her name
she told you my name is is Brenda or
Johanna you name it and you say okay but
then you forget and then it's too late
she's telling you what happened with
second husband that night in August and
how can you say that's really terrible
but please what is your name you cannot
do that but this thing about people
being closer do you really notice the
difference in the United States about
people standing close to each other when
they talk and in Europe they don't
that's why feeling maybe
anthropologists who tell me I'm all
wrong but my feeling is that I seen sort
of dental works of a lot of people that
I didn't want to say neon love that
reassuring why where do you see it where
do you notice it everywhere when you
have beers the name of beers outside in
the dark you are driving in the middle
of nowhere and you see the name of a
beer a famous beer on the name of some
other strange you know like in in blue
out of you know in all red it's very
reassuring I think neon lights are they
are are the sort of the perfect cure for
American anxiety m44 our anxiety too
because it's it tells you know
everything changes but those names are
there that's why i think was Bill Bryson
who said once that he says mrs.
MacDonald exit here and he thinks is an
order in actually exit and goes to a
mcdonald even if it doesn't feel like
having an amateur i'm not to that stage
but i feel the power of American
predictability there are motels McDonald
neon lights they are the horses can I
say oasis of American landscape the
place is where you know I go there for
rest I know what respect this next
subject tab I don't know how what you
can say about but you wrote about
Americans reaction to unpleasant body
odor well there is such thing as body
order number one and if you have too
many showers and if you use too many
sort of bath sort of shower gel bath
from whatever your body audit disappear
completely and maybe your fiance your
wife or whatever she may think that
you're then your body or is exactly the
same as a product you've been used over
the last two years you buy some other
product and she thinks she's lost you if
you think you are a different person is
that unusual to Americans
well it's a new number of showers you
have to remember that I come that I
lived in Britain for years in Britain is
a place where people have path in theory
in fact you cannot have a better every
day because this takes too long so that
their choice is not to have a bath and
where they think is is you know bday
which is in Italy is absolutely crucial
a bathroom must have a bday and b days
again it's a cultural thing in in
Britain and in America sometimes I think
you think the bdays are something to
wash your violence in because it's the
right shape but they're not and but in
America showers okay you take showers
you can do without bdays but do with our
bdays and showers and maybe windows in
the bathrooms I love the British but
sometimes they're really funny you say
that Americans have don't have a sense
of humor you have a sense of humor but
it's very special you don't like to joke
about sex race physical details being
fat to whatever bowl is and as a problem
because they were humorous about I i can
see politically political correctness is
a good thing in America what it means
you don't want to offend people fair
enough but sometimes i would say often
is just over the top and that takes away
the fun from life and humor i think that
it's a way of using the same subject in
an affectionate way and to take
everything away all the references not
only from exam in new york at the newark
time said the other day was fantastic
about taking out all references to to
you know races or whatever from famous
writers and then asking question based
on those details you have removed that's
political correctness wealthier correct
this doesn't get along with humor at all
what about swearing you're good at that
mmm i think you're good at that but
compared to the Italians you have a few
classics expression for instance you
have
something which is called a four-letter
word don't worry I want to use any of
those otherwise going to beat me you
beat people on c-span I probably you
probably did you may start today I want
to use videos ok I won't use any of that
you have something called four-letter
word we don't have an expression that
cannot be translate you know why because
we have a fantastic array and variety
but they go from two letters to 15
letters you are where you have classic
expression that you tend to insert you
look an American movie sometimes you're
the F word and F word which is which is
probably too much do we swear more than
battalions I according to your movies
yes you do I think them now movies are
you know represented America of their
own and they portray in America and I'm
not entirely sure it does exist when I
am around i don't hear people swearing
all the time in movies actors do nothing
else you even tell us in your book when
the House of Representatives the United
States Senate and the White House got
air conditioning yes the house in 28
Senate and 29 in this White House and 30
you see my book is useful but numbers
again numbers again I learned my lesson
I try to explain but again I used that
piece of information to explain how much
air conditioning has changed not only
production in this country and daily
life but has changed my little house on
15 30 and 34 street washington DC
because i realized that all the winners
were painted over it was impossible to
open and I looking at the at the age of
the paint I realized that more or less
it was probably 45 to 50 years old
exactly when air conditioning came came
to washington DC mall as that was the
time how about in italy how much air
conditioning comparatively we tend to
open windows does it get as hot there as
it does here it does in in well no it
doesn't to be honest i lived in
I live in the PIAA new rapid on in the
po valley and which is really hot and
when i came here and said come on people
I'm ready for everything you know I live
in the po valley I know what really hot
weather is and I came over and I lasted
15 minutes and then I shouting where is
air conditioning immediately rushed and
and actually wasn't working why well and
I called the number the telephone
emergency number on the on the label on
this other than the sticker on the air
conditioner at the first time ever I co
I did call a number on on a sticker it
proves how shocked I was you say
Americans like competition yes you do
why because I because they they're not
afraid of losing I think that the key
thing EULA you can like competition in
business in academia in broadcasting you
name it when you're not afraid of losing
when you think losing doesn't mean your
loser that's a big problem in Europe you
lost your a loser is difficult different
here you lost you try the list that's a
crucial thing when you fail in business
you're you're sort of Louisville for
life sometimes even the law about
failure it's called fundamental about
bankruptcy exactly that the translation
in Italy it's very dire it's very severe
you hardly can start again it's really a
problem and he said affects your life in
America you tried you were honest you
try hard you didn't do anything to do to
damage or or or cheat your shareholders
or your partners or whatever your must
be given another chance and and that's a
good thing and then you become
competitive to say you you know and then
if you know I want to I want to win I
may well lose but I want to win is there
more choice in the united states like
when you go into a grocery store and
you're going for Syria much choice too
much cereal I like to I know you are the
um Brian but I really like to turn this
around and ask you why on earth do you
need 54 58 different kinds of cereals
cereals are basically not necessary in
life they are so I don't think Skelos is
going to sponsor this program but I
think they're not necessary I mean you
can live without cereals there are
things you need water and meat
vegetables but cereals we don't use here
not only you have those but you have 54
different brands and some of them are
really morbid the combination are morbid
let me tell you do you think though they
would be there if there wasn't a demand
of course there is a demand and why
there is it the man I don't know i think
its people think that if you have less
than 30 brands or kind or something the
rationing is started i don't know i
think it's a you know being a rich
wealthy country and have having been
aware of the country for longer than we
all have been i was born in 1956 i have
i'm a few weeks older than the european
community and I was a lucky boy simply
because i was born in europe there was
in peace he was starting to pick up and
and and maybe that that these attitude
to life you'll see that in the book but
Italy was a poor country in the late 40s
and early 50s and so my father remembers
extremely well when there was not enough
food and they would eat meat and my
father is a lawyer but he remembers when
he they would eat meat once a week and
have one orange for special occasion in
the 40s or 30s America doesn't have
these memories you have the memory
you're only memory it's plenty of
everything which I'm not accusing it's a
fact and then maybe they're you 154 kind
of everything where did you meet your
wife she's from my hometown I travel all
over the place and she was born two
hundred yards from where I was born but
we met in our 20s her name ortensia what
kind of a name is that in Italy very
unusual it's a flower
in English is hydrangea in French is all
stars and in italia sort NC a-- he's a
nice flower very unusual name it was in
her family for some time so I think
Anton great hands were called Hortensia
how long have you been married 16 years
does she have a profession yes what'd
she do she works in a in she helps me a
lot she works as a professional help for
me very important to sort out and help
me with a lot of things that have to do
with you no money and taxes and all that
stuff and she wrote guidebooks very good
guidebooks in Italy and she's now very
busy helping children hospital she
devotes up and at least a third of a
working day for for that I'm very proud
of her back and the liner of your book
to get it there we go I want to show the
lined up here this little thing right
here I get it close up of that where did
this come from is that you before I
answer your question now I'm really
impressed by all the notes okay and
where you took them I'm not used to
interview a being so well prepared
anyway yes that is me that is me that is
a very good cartoons was drawn by Chris
Radel which is the Economist editorial
Christ be in the air the editorial
cartoonist normally he'd rose I am one
of the very few human beings he actually
drawn because he normally drones like
presidents and big shots everywhere but
because he's a friend he decided to give
me their little drawings i think is very
cute you say that Italians don't copy
the important things in American life
patriotism optimism and a sense of
personal responsibility instead they
copy vocabulary soft drinks jeans
hairstyles film songs and i'll just add
maybe they don't cereal i guess they
don't they don't buy cereal and no we
don't but at least that won't we don't
do why do they copy one thing and not an
in your opinion the answer is easy
because the thing you mentioned first
personal responsibility Patrick is good
Patrick Lee's sense of you duty
commitment they need effort it's you
really have to work hard to achieve
those the other thing that American
cells extremely well not only to eat be
able to all over the world and some of
them not all of them some of them are
not appreciated everywhere but
nonetheless a soldier screaming well
from Japan to Africa from here Southeast
Asia to South America those things easy
all you need is a credit card or your
currency and you buy those things easy
you want to buy the latest fad the
latest fad in you know in drugs you want
to buy the latest the song and and is
there to buy and of course drugs it's
bad that sometime we import those habits
songs are fantastic I'm very grateful
that you gave the word Bruce Springsteen
to name in there just to name one of
them but or Tom Waits but those things
are easy you're going to in the CD store
you buy a CD out and you feel American
while you're driving on I'm going out
Australian Italy listening to you know
drive all night or racing in the street
by Bruce Springsteen you think you're
American you are here because to the
sense of optimism responsibility the
feeling you know I tried I lost let me
try again the idea of you know coming
back doing that is different that it
takes
more changes more about tation more
patients sometimes it some people have
done that you don't talk a lot about a
lot of people in your book the first
person you mentioned is Thomas Jefferson
lunch I ask you about a moment the great
gadget man but you have reference on
three or four occasion to a united
states senator from Montana because he
leaves next door I'm guessing it was Max
Baucus he's the one I think he still
lives there is is I met him briefly I
met his wife a few times and she was
absolutely a terrific kind and nice and
she actually taught me and explaining
what to do about three boxes but I was
very disappointed i have to say because
the moment we moved we forgot to ask
some little permission about the van the
removal van which is very little was a
short little remove after a year we
didn't have that much furniture and then
van came parked too close to her house
apparently and she knew I went she knew
he was us and I I and she came and she
said take you know i'll give you i don't
know two minutes take this away and she
shouted I'm the wife of a senator I was
disappointed it's not something that I
expect that in my country sometimes you
don't know who i am no psyche so no yo
in Italian in America I was shocked I
was shocked a little disappointing not
yeah I'm sure she's a great lady and she
was just nervous that very day so when
has to be forgiving but I was a little
disappointed what about that the sense
of importance in a town like washing did
you see much of that yes and sometimes
people have a sense of importance where
they're not very important I think maybe
if you're an American senator or if you
are the vice pres in the United States
after all is in as a human or
understandable and then I this town
leaves the industry's power so one has
to accept that one thing that sometimes
I find a little disconcerting that
people ask you not who are you and how
are you but what you do
you do so they want to make sure they
done wasting time with you you said
earlier when we started that you've been
all over the country you've been here 30
times you got the recreation vehicle
some kind and went with your friends
across the country yes what year was
that again there was first time was in
77 was five friends and I came back with
my parents the in 87 they decided you
know America we want to go to Boston we
want to go to the Grand Canyon we want
to go to the monument valley and though
I had to arrange everything and pay for
it I say Papa but you're a lawyer you
are richer than i am and saying i don't
care you take me and we had a great time
i came back with my nephews and with my
family with my wife and son went to
yellowstone so I been to I guess 42
states believe you but I understood more
staying put in Washington DC in a little
house on thirty-fourth Street and
writing Chow America then traveling
around traveling around great fun but
you have to stay put stay quite and wait
for things to happen and for Americans
to behave like Americans and you have to
observe I am my I use the expression
beachcomber I am America is my own Beach
I go around and look for little things
those details that really tells you what
our country is about you could do the
same in Italy but if you go to foreign
in Spanish Rome in the week you would
understand stay put you come to my
little place you stay there for six
months you leave the daily life and you
really start to take the wreath at the
pace of a country you say that
understatement is alien to Americans
understatement yes it is but I go used
to that you want me to brag I can do
that very well i have an American cv
where I really proud of what I've done I
have an Italian cv where I sort of am I
try to achieve an aesthetic effect a
Bella Figura you know look what I've
done but it's different and have a
british TV where
actually asked forgive me for what I've
done the language the Americans like to
hear you use your time they do although
they want to eat me to pronounce a word
I linguine we don't have linguine you
have to end us you do not have lagrimas
not link wena yes we do have linguine
but they are not there are a few
restaurants where Americans go linguini
alfredo are an invention of america
america is so fantastically proud of
herself and so it's creative in a way
that you invented things that do not
exist in it you have a spare I i go to
shops moles very explain expensive suits
with brand names there are no brands in
Italy like Giovanni nice tiling and this
chap that's not exist are you paying a
lot of money you know you should really
know about this thing otherwise we get
you know we take too much advantage of
you we're about out of time but your son
how old is he nine what's his name
Antonia how long is he spent in the
United States and what is coming back in
a few days we're gonna meet in Chicago
and we gonna go into California to talk
about the book and he wants to be in
America he loves America America is his
playground you think it's a great fun
house his English non-existent well he's
passive English is is he understands the
mostest he watches cartoons and things
he understands what goes on but is try
and yunnan did if you want to learn
languages you don't have to be shy we
can't complete this but television you
write about you say it's constantly
agitating not this one how about that
what is it you mean by that people seems
to be in a frenzy all the time they have
sort of glassy eyes and and they tell
you everything they are excited
everything is so important dramatic
spectacular and maybe it's nothing it's
like a little accident next door or well
I don't like that I i think the
attention span of people is reduced to
two to it becomes too short if you just
have bum bum bum ba
bum you're probably thinking I'm being
clever and I want to be nice to see
Spain who add me for an hour here's the
cover of the book it's called ciao
America our guest is beppi sever Nene
thank you very much for joining thank
you Brian